en principio los manifestantes que ayer
se encontraban en los exteriores del
congreso tuvieron una reacción favorable
con gritos de júbilo aplausos y también
donde antes banderas felicitaron la
designación del presidente de sagasti y
le desearon el mejor de los éxitos en
paralelo diversos sectores del país
coincidieron en señalar la experiencia
en gestión de estado y sus cualidades
políticas
justamente martín vizcarra también se
mostró satisfecho y el destacó entre
todos porque dijo que solamente una
persona con cualidades democráticas
puede brindar el soporte que en estos
momentos el país necesita